you ladies are playing or taking on
three characters in history that focus
just don't really know a whole lot about
how do you hope that learning about
these characters will impact film
audiences well I hope that we will
influence the next crop of stem
enthusiasts boys and girls yeah it's
scary that there's been a rapid decline
of people of color in the stem programs
especially women for me I was told as a
little girl that math and science wasn't
for girls just don't silly yourself with
us for boys so I'm hoping to give little
girls a dream that I never knew I was
allowed to dream this movie is really
meant to inspire that generation who
like us when we read the script we had
no clue who Mary Jackson was who Dorothy
Vaughn was who Katherine Johnson were
the women who were directly responsible
for getting our first American in the
space we didn't know that so hopefully
now they can look to these women who had
to overcome so many obstacles these
women didn't allow the sexism or the
racism or the opinions of the people
around them to stop them from reaching
and achieving their goals what's the
most surprising thing that you learned
about Katherine Johnson in the end and
these women throughout filming the most
surprising thing to me just that why did
it take so long to hear about this and
then it's just very inspiring to see
such intelligent driven people portrayed
in a moving it's it's wonderful and then
understand the obvious that these these
numbers had to be computed by hand which
was of course they did because we hadn't
really entered the computer age of
course they were then we're and then
they were done by women wow that's
interesting and then their name work
computers long before machines were
called that and these three women you
know just their force of will eventually
emerged and and like I say the cream was
able to come to the top you know you you
shocked us you can ask you you were this
bill but you know a thing or two about
music as well talk about Pharrell
soundtrack it is so if the music is so
compelling with these scenes oh
absolutely for real has been a musical
hero of mine for quite some time and the
music is really his his love letter to
these
American heroes three african-american
female protagonists not arguing not
helping each other to consoling each
other for divorce but they were
scientists engineers and mathematicians
technolog technologically advanced you
know here comes the story that involves
science and NASA two things that I've
been obsessed with since I was a child
and it actually happened in hampton
roads in 1960s where I'm from so for me
it was like man I got to be a part of
this story your computer at nest and
then women handle that sorted yes get
that women do some things at NASA mr.
Johnson and it's not because we're
skirts because we wait glasses don't you
know
[Music]
you